mean go ahead on helpful advice with
Bobby at kalila hi guys my name is
Romney and I want to ask you guys
especially Bobby what do you think this
was molestation or was I just gay when I
was 10 my cousin who was 14 forced me to
suck his dick and then later penetrated
my [ __ ] this happened a couple times
in a row now and I'm now 19 and has
never been in any and I've never been in
any relationship because it has [ __ ]
me up mentally and I can't stop thinking
about it I'm afraid of getting a
girlfriend now because I feel she judged
me how do I deal with my [ __ ] up life
no thanks it's not it's just being 19
okay this is my opinion
if some people win genetic lotteries
okay and those people in high school
that are like the hot guy or the popular
guy or the jog later in life they don't
get [ __ ] okay they don't generally I
think his question was did you get
Mallis no no I'm gonna address that babe
I'm gonna address the why I would
address it I'm gonna address it when
addressed okay so I think him being 19
as it is without the [ __ ] ass raping
right did people asked him so I was like
you know I feel I'm not confident I was
like that
I was unfuckable I couldn't do it I felt
like because you know I had some gay
[ __ ] in my past because I was molested
and well not kind of stuff that it's
probably that it wasn't that it was that
I need to find the confidence to go for
the women that I wanted because the
level of women that was presented to me
at 19 just wasn't good enough and I know
that maybe I wasn't physically like you
know there you know but in my mind
Papo deserves the best alright so what
I'm saying is is that yes it did
probably affect you right it is a [ __ ]
up thing that happened but let me tell
you something right now that's happened
to so many dudes through the history of
time family members doing gay [ __ ]
family members doing you know when
you're growing up doing stuff or you're
doing stuff with your friends that are
like weirdly sexual you know
people play doctor and stuff kids and
stuff but also let's be clear what he
did to you was absolutely right wrong-o
conflicting answers no you're right I
was gonna say wrong it's absolutely a
ten-year-old child probably overpowered
by a bigger guy but also like your
concern about being open with women or
Oh being open with a girl about your
experience might be a little bit just
out of your pure fear oh by the way
Bobby's been holding his poop this whole
pie yeah I think that you should give
girls a lot more credit for being
understanding people I think that when I
was even let's I put myself back to
being let's say 1718 and I meet a guy
and if he were to tell me hey like I was
molested at the age of 10 my cousin did
this I I wouldn't think of him any
differently I wouldn't it's just that
she's that kind of [ __ ] just happens
that wasn't your fault you didn't have
control over the situation and I think
you need to give women and girls more
credit I think that she'd be completely
understanding of it not only things that
she wouldn't want to [ __ ] you because of
it you know like I it just seems
unlikely that she would use that as a
reason to not have sex with you I mean
I'm having sex with someone who's
voluntarily sucked multiple male dicks
and if it doesn't matter to me I think
that it's not what happens he wasn't
gonna matter to majority of women and if
it matters to her she's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you should just move on to
somebody else
she's not the right person yeah yeah so
don't make that your first thing you say
though yeah I mean don't know hey I've
been a straight don't do that
yeah I mean this is also it's none of
her business what happened to you at the
age of 10 if you choose to never
disclose that that's also your you know
that's also your right but if it's
something you feel the need to disclose
because it's affecting you and it
explains a lot of like the way you are I
then then yeah disclose it but it's I
don't think it's it's gonna push women
away
[Music]